the european commission today tightening
export rules making it easier for the
block to stop covid 19 vaccine
deliveries
to britain and other countries the
controversial decision comes amid rising
frustration in europe
over the slow rate of vaccination the eu
says it will ensure producers aren't
sending out supplies
needed by member countries rapid fire
jabs are the order of the day in the uk
even churches like the renowned
westminster abbey have been commandeered
in the battle against the virus
the strategy strategy's seen some 30
million uk residents vaccinated so far
just under 50 percent of the population
all
eu member countries put together have
only managed 57 million
the eu had ordered adequate supplies
from producers but pharma firms have
failed to keep
up curevac will supply
405 million shots but its vaccine hasn't
been licensed yet for eu distribution
roughly the same quantities are on order
from astrazeneca
along with the recently approved johnson
and johnson jab
the eu wants 300 million doses from
sanofi
as soon as the european medicines agency
gives the go-ahead
the same number from biontech moderna is
expected to
supply 160 million shots
all those pharma companies have
production lines in the eu
their most important locations are in
germany france spain
belgium italy and austria and production
is being ramped up over the coming
months
the european commission has been angered
by the site of vaccines from eu
production
being exported whilst they're in short
supply here
this year between the beginning of
february to mid-march 41.5 million
covert 19 shots were exported from the
eu
to the uk the americas asia south africa
and australia the uk alone got 10
million of those doses
yet the european commission says british
swedish producer astrazeneca
has barely supplied the eu with 30 of
the quantities agreed
what europe's vaccination program needs
now is a shot in the arm
well for more on this dispute over the
astrazeneca vaccines i'm joined now by
our man in brussels george martinez good
evening to you
georg there is a lot of um blaming and
finger pointing across both sides of the
english channel
who is at fault here the eu the uk or is
it astrazeneca
uh clearly astrazeneca has not been able
to keep promises
it has made that i think that's a fact
then the uk obviously made a lot of good
pragmatic decisions but also
they had the quantities they had the
vaccines and a lot of those vaccines
as we have heard uh have come from the
european union not just
by not just astrazeneca but also
bioentech pfizer and madonna 10 million
doses
what the eu was not aware of or what
they did not calculate in their strategy
is
that the uk had a uk first clause
in their contract so one way of looking
at it is i think
is to say that the eu was a bit too
naive was
trusting too much into open markets in
their strategy
of getting vaccines yeah that's a good
way to put it and we know today the
european union announced tougher export
rules on vaccines
are are we on the verge of what could be
a period of vaccine nationalism
i'd say that is exactly what the
brussels institutions hope to avoid
and in that light you also have to
understand that legislation that has
been put forward by the commission now
to restrict uh the mechanism that
observes
exports of of vaccines it is not just a
deterrent
for countries uh to play by the rules
but it's also an
incentive and in that light you could
also see
a joint statement by the european union
and the uk
that has just been published talking
about creating a win-win situation
working together hand in hand on
openness and global cooperation
all right dw's gabriel matas with the
ladies tonight from brussels
gee york thank you